with a a real classic I think here kids
yeah dirty-ass CRT monitor you're going
up first what's what's that first on the
menu today first on the menu today is a
wonderful beat em up game called Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles for turtles in time
we're gonna do a little time-traveling
we're gonna get some people up we're
gonna fight shredder it's gonna be a fun
time yeah perhaps no more apt to be
titled name for a speedrun then Charles
in time absolutely so what part of the
game what party picking what to a
chapter one you can do the whole thing
we are gonna do the whole thing well
most of it most of it we may skip a
stage if we get lucky okay is there some
crazy trick that I can do where we might
even be able to to bypass in one of the
stages so let's see if we can make that
happen
yeah so where where did the rules fall
down I always feel like whenever I jump
into the speedrunning community I have
to like we assess oh there is rules
litigation yeah we people will argue for
days and months about every rule we
possibly can and like I love it but it
depends on the game so like skipping a
chapter fair game as long okay like yes
in this particular situation it is so
we're actually gonna have to use both of
the controllers here okay I'm gonna be
controlling two turtles not just one
right for a portion of the game and
that's gonna allow me to hopefully do
the skip and if we don't get it you know
the worst worse comes to worse you gotta
beat the stage normally okay big deal
what's the warning a speedrun on this
one until the time the the record yes
I believe it is what 18 19 18 minutes
and 19 seconds okay that's pretty fast
it is fast well what do you reckon
you'll pull off today I guess we'll
probably get a little closer to maybe
the 20 low 20 20 minutes
ish and how much would how long would it
take a 5 is to play it's been a while
since I played tells though if I was to
go back and play now
resuming I didn't like die a lot what
would you if you didn't die a lot it
would probably take maybe like 45
minutes to an hour okay I would say
that's pretty so we're gonna be we're
gonna be doing a lot of things to speed
that up alright it's just opening the
twitchchat here and listen to my own
voice I coming through if you have any
questions by all means put them in this
pitch jot and I will run
to our two experts here all right I'm
gonna get this thing started
yeah let's kick it off do it so first of
all we gotta go into the options here
and just change a few things around
we're gonna make it the hardest
difficulty right we know we don't want
things to be too easy now I prefer the
control setup type see we don't need any
extra lives but we do need to make the
player - manual so that you actually are
the one controlling the - not not the
computer more or less and this back
attack is a pesky thing where like if an
enemy comes up behind you you'll turn
around and attack them right but once
again that's taking control out of the
player's hand so you want to have full
control of your turtle at all times so
we're good to your experience we're good
to go on our settings and we're gonna
kick it off so we're gonna start with
just one turtle okay we're gonna start
with Raph and Raph happens to be not
only the strongest turtle Raph but they
couldn't fit in the full names it saves
time just to say the first good point
yeah yeah it's easy Raph is what his
buddies called exactly what of Leo Leo
is not gonna get to be a part of our run
here although you may see Don and Mike
possibly oh let's see let's see what
happens it makes him sound like bus
drivers mine there used to be a radio
show called Don and Mike this is a
really long time I think I'm probably
dating myself but anyways I am playing a
game from the 90s so that says something
too I suppose
anyway Raph he's the strongest he's the
fastest we're going straight into the
Big Apple it's 3:00 a.m. kraang has
captured the Statue of Liberty and we're
out to get it back he did a third
massive brain in its belly yes and he
did this in the afternoon but the
turtles still decided that they should
wait until 3:00 a.m. to take action they
were having a good night yeah they were
eating pizza you know which pizza is
important in this run so I just got a
pizza there that does replenish your
health all the way and the reason that's
important is you actually lose health
when you do some of your special attacks
all right
so you kind of got to make sure that you
get that back under control you you
don't want to you don't want to be
taking deaths now so there's Krang he's
already out to get us
it looks ok it looks like he's doing
well yeah he's doing all right we'll see
him again
named for the body he was in or was it
all just crank I think it's all just
cranes but I couldn't tell you for sure
this this is a I don't want to get the
things wrong you know yeah if anyone in
the chat knows Turtles cannon please by
all means let us know bumped on Sunday
and he's saying Don is the best turtle I
don't know if I can agree with that
that's a bold statement yeah no no
opinion is wrong but that's about as
close this is Baxter he flies and then
you got a you got to take him out over
there near the edge cuz he has to blow
up and fall off the roof and he will
only do that at that very upper
left-hand corner so why I take him out
over there so it was that even even
there did you quickly kill him in a way
that oh yes that was that was a quick
kill and we made sure that he jumped off
the roof as soon as possible so I'm
gonna be utilizing a couple different
throw maneuvers the slam throws one of
them gonna use that right here I'm gonna
try to use it nice I didn't use it too
quite great effect you can also do that
screen throw with you can get you can
just get rid of enemies get them off the
screen and you can kill multiple enemies
when you're doing those those tactics
sometimes you do get hit by a stage
hazard and you can see any difference
between the colored ninjas in their
style or difficulty or they just like to
mix it up they have different amounts of
hit points the purple guys have the
lowest hit points and Raph is the only
turtle that can take them out in one
shot so you can see I'm doing that kind
of flying kick yeah to take those guys
out like none of the other turtles they
can do that move but it's just not as
powerful so I mean while I'm struggling
a little here we get we're getting some
of the tougher enemies going on so are
you saying then like objectively or look
like Ralph is the best turtle like
indicate at least like he's definitely
the most overpowered to no question okay
no question about it it actually varies
depending on the game like that's true
the old and pendo game that was
I want to say Donatello actually don't
know turtle but then with the staff yes
in the first turtles I believe so
it's on done it's like he's got the most
damage and he also has the most range
because he has a staff so just always
pick Donatello or Don yes is this what
the hell is this
this is metalhead he's he's actually
trying to be a turtle but he's he's a
robot of some sort so do I just not
remember like turtle or or are these
made up no this was New York this
happened you know this is real life in
the 90s there were a very radical time
in many ways have you guys seen the new
movie uh I have not no no all right so
we're gonna we're gonna talk about the
90s for a second like now I haven't
we're gonna bring in our buddy doc okay
here we go so we got we got two turtles
now and Don
Don is gonna serve a purpose here I've
done the same surfboard
no they're just sharing space right now
to make sure I don't get hit by any
enemies because I am controlling both of
them you you you guys go help out if you
if you want I can give one of you the
always thick but that's that might be
ill-advised since you haven't practiced
I'm terrified I think that you're
probably better with both controllers
then at least if I was helping I decided
all right
that's NES games are not my forte okay
so we're gonna we're gonna take Don out
actually here now there's a reason for
this okay that's because we don't want
him to tag along for the entire game we
just wanna tag along for a little while
while we do this glitch hopefully like I
said it's a very very different we doing
the glitch this reminds me of like
playing Super Stardust and like knowing
the way through because these levels
were never like randomly generated they
were always you could just learn the
pattern real good alright so dumb alien
these are pizza monsters okay oh my or
Geiger's beat samosas Ridley Scott's
beats emotion system right I think when
you get mutated stuff down in the sewer
and then it eats some pizza
just strange things happen I guess
darksied would have been better with
pizza monsters great job all right so
now we're gonna take on the Rat King he
is the king of the sewers or at least he
thinks he is we're about to show
we're the the real rulers of the sewers
down here you guys know what a real rat
King is a real one yeah well they're not
really real but if you if you google rat
king it is a mythological beast which is
basically a bunch of rats that are like
stuck together because they're like
tails got stuck together oh yeah poop on
each other and they get tangled up and
stuff it's like one big lump of rats
sounds pretty terribly like old like
it's old Laura yeah medieval yeah like
yeah like beliefs like they don't
actually exist but there you go there's
your a little bit of medieval myth the
lore see I like the Dark Soul Brad Lord
to dissemble crowns on them they're much
more much cuter yeah that's one literal
all right so you're playing with both
these guys man yeah so I'm gonna let
Raph do most of the heavy lifting here
cuz he is like I said the strongest and
the fastest Don can help out a little
bit but we got to be careful we want to
don't want to scroll the screen too far
here because this is where we're gonna
be doing the glitch hopefully allegedly
so I'm gonna get these guys lined up
over here and a little Running Start got
it alright so we just we don't want to
play anymore we're just you know what we
don't need to fight these guys let's
just go to the end of the stage let's
take the oh you know what let's not even
take the elevator let's just go to that
we don't need the yellow hair does that
give like found out that is a very long
story essentially a bunch of people
founded independently we're gonna fight
shredder now now we're actually or not
it's we got we got that back at the
beginning of the stage now we'll fight
shredder are you confused yet so a lot
of crazy things are happening there but
essentially a bunch of people discovered
this playing this as you know in their
childhood and reported it and eventually
somebody decided you know hey I should
actually look into this to see if this
is a real thing because so many people
have said that it is a real thing yeah
and indeed they were able to figure it
out and say okay this is actually a
thing that can happen in a video game so
we essentially skip that whole stage
there and this is where I do want to get
rid of Donatello and we have
successfully done that which you can see
Don has now become Mike if you'll notice
up there at the top
I mean everyone's favorite turtle mic so
like I said everybody Michael everybody
but Leo gets to play okay so so now
we're just gonna go back to Raph because
carrying you know carrying Don along
would just be too difficult
Don's a real POS a little bit but he's
some people's favorite turtles so we
don't wanna be too hard people can't
have not great opinions that's true they
can be not wrong but closer on so
essentially what's really happening
there is there's a the mousers are the
only enemies in the game that can
actually attack both turtles at once if
they're on the same plane which is what
I organized and then there's a warm-up
phase to a turtles hitbox when they're
starting an attack and if you're able to
press the button the attack button in
that warm-up phase then the game gets
confused and it just doesn't know what
to do so it sends you to the end of the
stage just like I don't understand
what's happened which time did you save
over a minute okay cuz we skipped
essentially a whole stage there see I
love that look too not just because of
what it is but there are glitches like
that in other games but usually just
teleports you right away right but this
is like the game notes I don't know what
to do but they haven't walk out anyways
I guess the casual we're gonna leave yes
it's not we just teleported away yeah
yeah it looks like they're doing it by
choice you know yeah it's like yeah we
don't want to fight anymore we're bored
with you guys so do you really need to
do this where are those guys these are
the stone warriors and they are tough
yeah I mean they're made of stone and
they have football helmets on so that'll
do it also earlier I saw there was
dinosaurs what's going on yes we have
now successfully traveled through time
we are we are in the prehistoric age at
this point
so apparently ninjas are just ubiquitous
at the right time this is correct yes
shredder not only sent us back in time
but he sent all of these minions back
because in part he figured that would be
the best use of time travel and usually
find firkins near fossils so it makes
sense well since I'm gonna guess it's
gonna get a couple more dinosaurs
through here thanks for trying boy those
guys now Raph while he is the strongest
and the fastest he is also the weakest
oh no you don't want to get hit too much
now you want to be the one doing the
hitting
one of his sends he does when he gets
hit sounds like he's like cached meowing
that one there
that is his special taxes slash this is
a very very difficult boss but he leaves
just enough space that you can start out
behind him and he's facing the wrong way
take him out here like he even slashes
at you when he lands but still you know
in the intro yeah beat him off the
screen yeah so a very tough boss he said
he's done yeah you can one cycle in
there if you were normally fighting this
guy he probably would kill you you would
game over
and have to start the stage all over
again he's really that tough but if you
know if you know how to speed run you
can just get right behind him and take
him out so presumably you couldn't walk
the the phase where he was teleporting
in you were we would have been stuck so
you had to walk there before he jumped
in yes that's correct
so now we've traveled a little bit
forward in time we are now on the boat
12 any of the open water it doesn't give
you a year right you're just in the boat
arrow oh yeah but yes the boat there
well there's gonna be pirates there's
there's gonna be some pirates I believe
at some point I reckon book time okay
massive arrows stupidly long so there's
also gonna be a guy I call him
cannonball guy he he's he's pretty rough
he can actually just with deadly
accuracy shoot these cannonballs at you
and most of the time it's pretty much
impossible to avoid but he knows it well
no he's over there so we're gonna have
alright well he didn't get to hit me
because the stone warrior guy hit me so
cannon ball guy missed his chance these
cannonballs questionable really sturdy
ship yes this is a very well made ship
also I like that the chains with the
license plate hanging off it actually
notice that oh yeah yeah it's how it
happened safety very important of
pirating vessels
this has been actually it's actually
wood it's just a wood veneer on Alameda
frame this this is like the original
safety regulations boat before anybody
else did it yeah they were doing it
before it was cool yeah shredder really
like he's dangerous but he cares about
worker safety that's why they were
pirates because it's just a health and
safety dogs didn't exist yet so they
have to take it on themselves
it really is this was the first Union
yeah alright so we're gonna have two
enemies to fight here but we actually
only have to take out one of them and
then they'll fight each other it's some
bebop and rocksteady through Monkey
Island nice now I took I got hit there
at the end I took took a death too but
that's okay they're fighting each other
so nice well so that's that's not a
problem
so we're gonna go from the boat we're
gonna go to the train now oh the Train
era the Train okay yes good
I guess depends on what kind of train is
there an airplane next they should have
done that why did they why did they skip
over airplanes I don't know no we're not
gonna get well we're gonna get some
flying things but not necessarily an
airplane
oh they're tired of Iraq I mean it
wouldn't be an early 90s like we beat
him up before wasn't until at least one
train level I mean like there's been
cowboy games with trains has been cowboy
games where you're a cow with trains I
mean even like Tiny Toons games had
trains yeah yeah yeah and that game is
also by Konami so this it has a very
similar soundtrack to this game as well
just the parallax scrolling and then
they just speed it up just want an
excuse to speed it up I think parallax
scrolling is one of the greatest things
that should never be used again I'm so
glad there are so many games that have
all I want now is just a bunch of cattle
to run past to jump on top of him
what's he saying TV time oh please gotta
get that Pizza Pizza Pizza
is the huh this is gonna take out all of
these guys so we can just run away now
see that's bloated to death now we get
to fight leatherhead the crocodile or
alligator one of us here with the red
hair it looks Meyerson me
green skin at all so you know exactly
where he's running as well yes he's
gonna go to the same spot and you can
only hit him three times per cycle right
before he does the Thriller dance off
the edge there so now we're gonna now
we're gonna get a little further into
the future though so we've gone from
1885 I believe we're gonna go train in
2020 I watched ooze then okay this these
are the roads like everybody that's my
commute yes I'm Cisco dis morning yeah
hoverboards I mean the hoverboards are
out right I mean there's a lot of people
I'm sure you guys are aware that right
around with those things yeah those are
actually banned at sgdq because of the
hotel rules and I couldn't be happy
really yeah it's like we follow the
hotel rules they don't want people
running around and all right so we're
gonna have our first encounter with
Krang here stage one we didn't really
get to take him on at all but we're
gonna we're gonna fight him at the end
of this autoscroller
I say how soon has the best comment of
the TWiT shot so far at turtle amiibos
that was look he does look that they
should make a total some time to me boy
look at that crystal ball I mean they
can jump off okay just say I'm very
impressed by how they say fair you are
about this incredibly difficult thing
you're doing right
well yeah so far it has it's gone fairly
well but things could change quickly
because we're coming up on some of the
the hardest things in fact the next
stage Starbase is truly truly very
difficult and this this boss fight is
actually really tricky as well but I'm
gonna take an intentional death despite
the fact that I only have two lives
ordaining I'm gonna take an intentional
death because so I have 16 health right
now right and it takes three health to
do a special move so that means I have
five specials those deal 16 damage
apiece if I take a death I get a free
health refill and then I get Wow I get
five more specials so we're gonna go all
the way down to one HP and then I'm just
gonna get hit intentionally and then
we're gonna have five more specials to
work with so we'll be able to beat Krang
down pretty quickly
I hope I'm it's really upsetting that
they change the perspective 90 degrees
but the city remained in the background
that's like churning my stomach in them
the weight like a virtual reality bug
speaking of which one of our later
speedruns alright so there it is we were
able to hit 10 specials that's the
fastest that you can kill Krang he is
done so normally what he does is he
actually goes off the screen but you
guys didn't get an opportunity to see
that and that takes about like 20
seconds he'll just go off the screen and
these things will fall down out of the
sky and how did you stop that happening
because I manipulated how much health he
had and the positioning and all kinds of
stuff to make sure that we took him out
and that intentional death also so I got
to like the second phase yeah he never
even got there so now we're now we're
going further into the future were going
into star base and you may have noticed
Krang got away there so we're gonna have
to see him we're gonna have to see him
again unfortunately god I hate that guy
I know
20100 this is little bit further into
the future alright this is a little bit
more believable or I guess yeah sure
that's some like cultural context area
like has Britain rejoined the EU at this
stage so the brexit predict the
predictions from 19:00 and these SNES
games yeah all they knew were fully
aware look at all these guys which
turtle voted leave dawn yes the bend on
Don Ponce yeah look at all this
I'd be slightly more futuristic ninja
men are they the same they're pretty
much the same I'm just uh yeah shredder
he got kind of lazy I think you know I
mean yeah those takes up memory he
already did have robots in New York so
like it's good point
defending this is a regression a little
bit listen you really need anything
super fancy a massive DV archives visit
the mall he did give that big cannonball
was the Cannonball he did get that big
cannonball yes and another one took a
green cannonball that's it that's him he
just squats on them it's a future
cannonball oh he gave the stone guys
rocket launchers oh that's good maybe
look like do Marines yeah I mean look
they already existed like rocket launch
has already existed but I guess they
weren't smart enough to use until now
David is just more portable like they
didn't have like underhand rocket
launchers yeah very like
off-the-shoulder
kind of thing you know it's like it's
like future space rocket launchers that
like make the bullet happen or something
they're holding them like shotguns do
they fire rockets people trip ever
because I got to enjoy all the perils of
time again without any of the difficulty
of actually playing it and also
incredibly fast yes okay so now we're
gonna encounter Krang again now this
this is a little more annoying because
he can actually fly at Heights where
it's difficult to hit him so he can take
a really long time to defeat okay you
know the spaceship now he's lost his
body
shredders just watching in the
background yeah he's he's rooting for
Krang but I don't think it's gonna work
out too well for Krang in the end here
rest in peace Krang you double pizza
baby he does look like something he'd
put on the pizza yeah definitely topping
yeah like a anchovy or something they
hailed something about plug bad about a
good pizza topping there's a lot of hate
that doesn't deserve
hey yeah this is what was it Futurama
this is probably the anchovies might
already be extinct by this days yeah
look at the other option Futurama was
fry opens up the candy the anchovies
just come out and fly spaceship around
but actually it seems like a Futurama
twist like could happen actually
how much is Oh dawn there we go he was
actually a while well he was he kept
going up too high so he's up too high
he's really hard to hit it was hard to
tell if he was too high or just
the top of the screen so now it's
finally it's finally time to take on
shredder shredder may or may not use
performance-enhancing drugs I why not
confirm but there's something funny
about how muscular he gets there also a
human growth hormone yeah there's
something going on so we want to just
corner him at the edge of the screen
well that would make sense because he's
not even goes shredder anymore he's
called shred
he's just getting shredded that that's
true hit the gym come on Ralph so what's
the trick on this link all right where
he's gonna be yeah and then I mean we we
died that's okay
he doesn't have a lot of HP left so he's
done he's gonna go off the roof and
that's it great was in time we're done
congratulations I'm not sure if we were
actually timing there's probably about
20 minutes I would I would guess we'll
give it a pretty fast it was pretty fast
it was pretty fast we've recovered the
Statue of Liberty which is what's
important in New York City it had been
taken by Krang see we actually skipped
that cutscene you know a speed runners
we just we can't have time to watch
those cutscenes we got to just move
right you've always got time for April
O'Neill oh oh yeah ends winter yeah oh
yeah look at him they're exploring he's
he's out there in public like he's not
trying to hide anymore he's just like
hey we saved the Statue of Liberty let
me get some credit too guys once a
satchel of Liberty has been stolen and
saved by turtles yeah in a different
world all right
it's the one thank you so much for
coming on